I'm a history buff American history buff
and I hear people saying all the time to
selection this is the most important
election of our lifetime and then I go
back on a look at the footage and I
realize that they've been saying that
pretty much every election of this
century this is the most important
election of your lifetime do you think
this really is the most important
election of our lifetime it's the most
terrifying election well which makes it
the most important I mean this is this
guy Trump you know he just says one
thing after another that makes you think
that maybe he's got suited he he went
after the gold star family the Khans
member kazeer khan the father icky
zircon held up the Constitution and said
mr. Trump you haven't read it you can
borrow mine and take mine
and Trump tweeted what does he think
gives him what gives him the right what
gives him the right to say I haven't
read the Constitution
[Applause]
he's just amazing like Michael Bloomberg
I think said it in an interesting way at
the Democratic convention he said and he
was obviously referring to Trump we we
need to elect someone who is sane and
competent that is such a low bar really
yeah yeah how many how many in the
audience just curiously how many think
you're saying and competent okay how
many how many think you're prepared to
be President
okay see that Sam it's a low bar it's a
low bar yeah yeah yeah it's got me
interested in getting into politics
again I I think if I I think I could
yeah no you can't do this you can't do
that everything Trump's done I can't
I still can't hiss like a cat I still
can't wiggle my ass maybe wrong you
might be wrong I might be wrong yeah all
right I'm getting in folks
no it's too importantly and everyone got
to get out and vote
right cuz this scary it's 78 days I
think 78 days
you